it's chapter one scared the pants off of
audiences when it debuted in 2017
becoming the highest-grossing horror
movie of all time and leaving fans
hungry for more and it's chapter 2 is
certainly keeping pace with its
predecessor at the box office according
to the Los Angeles Times the film scored
91 million dollars in its first weekend
making it the second biggest horror
movie opening of all time behind its
2017 predecessor together the two films
are likely to rake in a worldwide
box-office take somewhere in the
neighborhood of 1.5 billion dollars and
this begs the question will there be in
its chapter 3
please note we'll be discussing a few
plot points from King's novel and the
two films so some spoilers are coming
right at you well both hit movies are
reasonably faithful to the source
material stephen king's epic 1986 novel
of the same name they weren't completely
so central set pieces solely appear in
the films like Stan's run-in with a
creepy lady from the painting in the
first film and Bill's Hall of Mirrors
nightmare in the second one of the most
notable changes as a fact that it's
chapter 2 doesn't end with the same city
destroying storm that concludes the book
the difference could be telling
following the success of its chapter 1
studio execs may have advised director
and the MU Scotty to leave the door open
for a third installment but if that's
the case he certainly isn't admitting it
in 2017 he did discuss the possibility
of splitting chapter 2 into separate
films telling variety it would make
sense because it would give me more turf
to develop the characters and a more of
a canvas to develop the journey but to
be honest there was the conversation
about that and now we are designing the
story as one single film of course
nothing motivates studio executives like
big bucks
and if newline ultimately decides to
greenlight a third chapter there's a
number of tracks the film could take in
fact penny wise actor bill skarsgård has
mentioned that he and mu sketchy have
kicked around an idea for a third hit
movie in a recent sit down with Joe Blow
the actor opened up about those talks
saying that Andy and I have discussed
ideas what a third movie would look like
I don't think it's quite what people
expect it's something different the
first two stories of the book and the
second film is to end of that story so
we would do something quite literally
off-book skarsgård goes on to reveal
that there are a few ideas floating
around I feel like I've done what I come
with the incarnation of penny wise as we
know him
so I think it would be a cool idea to
change up a few things
without going into too much detail there
is a story that were kind of excited
about but it's way too early to say but
we'll see we'll see the idea of a new
incarnation of penny wise is certainly
an intriguing one although it's safe to
say they're about a million ways to get
that concept wrong obviously any
additions to King's masterpiece would
require a deft touch but at least mu
Scotty has already demonstrated his
considerable talent just by bringing it
successfully to the big screen
of course even if at chapter three never
comes to fruition penny wise could
always return to theaters and a supercut
of the first two films and guess what
Luo sketchy is definitely considered the
idea as he recently told cinema blend I
am thinking of a supercut which is
basically the two movies taught one
after the other adding everything that
was lifted from them for length purposes
great scenes that are more character
moments or things that we had to lift
for other reasons I'm also very excited
about shooting extra material
well that news should certainly put a
smile on your face of course if that
plan comes to fruition
we hope we're given an intermission or
two because watching an it super Kurt
was certainly gobbled up a gargantuan
amount of time considering that mu
Scotty has already put this idea out in
the public sphere we're thinking a super
Kirk could actually happen as to whether
we'll ever really see an it chapter
three we suspect that the likelihood is
pretty slim and all things considered
that's probably for the best the novel
spins an epic and phenomenally
terrifying yarn but expanding the story
would almost certainly do the book at
the service check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite horror movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bowel so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]